[Musique]
Je m'ennuie tellement de vivre Je me réveille tous les
matins dans le même lit Je m'habille
et je mange le même petit-déjeuner
puis je fais le même trajet pour aller travailler J'ai 28
ans et je suis terrifié c'est tout
c'est un rêve bien en partie je
sais que deux semaines c'est long pour moi d'
être absent
parce que je vais à peu près bien à
peu près tu vas bien j'ai juste l'
impression que tout le monde se moque de moi
alors d'habitude je vois mon père mort je
n'étais pas dans un accident j'ai été tué et
il m'entraîne à voyager dans le temps avec
ta capacité nous pouvons changer ce qui s'est passé
pour que je puisse le sauver d'être assassiné
tu te pousses trop fort tu fais
Moi, je ne peux pas faire ça, je ne peux pas continuer à finir
dans des endroits où aller voir des trucs et manquer
choses
[Musique
] tout tourne autour de vos émotions dont vous avez besoin pour les
ressentir sans les laisser devenir
vous comment puis-je faire cela juste des respirations profondes
[Musique]
Hey Baby Cakes des flux de souffrances de toute une vie
sont transportés à travers votre esprit
et votre corps
[Musique]
même  les bons sentiments
doivent aussi abandonner les maisons
qui ne peuvent pas être qui tu es si tu veux
être libre bien sûr le seul de ma
famille qui croit en moi est le
mort pour l'instant
toi